what's up guys before we begin today's
video i just want to say a big thank you
to squarespace for sponsoring today's
video
and our youtube channel make sure to
stick around till after the video
because i'll be talking more about
squarespace with you guys
[Music]
hola mi kente have you guys noticed
right now in the one second i've started
this vlog that i'm vlogging on a brand
new camera
ah you guys probably didn't even notice
but yeah look
i got a new camera so this camera
nikki she actually has this very same
camera but the mark
ii and i have the mark iii it's the
canon g7x
mark iii and so every time that she
vlogs i'm always like dude i love your
camera it's like so
like it just it makes everyone look
really good and then it's also like
really
compact and my camera that i've had
which has been the
sony this one this is the camera i've
had for many years it is the
sony rx100 mark
four this is a mark iv so i've had this
for many years and it's
it's served me well but recently it
started crapping out on me and that's
why i asked nikki like oh my gosh what's
the camera that you got
because it's cyber monday and there's
deals and i want to see if i get a deal
on
on your camera so she told me and then i
ordered it and i got it like three days
later
it was so fast but this is the first
time i'm actually vlogging with it
so yay new camera hopefully you guys can
tell the difference at least somehow
maybe i don't know but this camera also
it was driving me insane because it
never
focused ever and then also this button
up here
it got really gunky out of like from
using it so many times and like at the
beach or whatever
and i could never zoom in either this
camera here is nice and brand new
now and i get to use it finally for the
first time today
and the reason why i picked up the
camera and started vlogging is because
isaac
wants to rearrange his room alright so
this is isaac's room
this guy was over here but we currently
just moved it really quick and then
that's when i was like oh wait we're
moving stuff let's walk
so anyway that dresser slash bench
thingy was here right
and the reason why he wants to move this
oh there you are you want to
tell them the reason why you want to
move your room yeah cause
whenever i play i can't really keep my
windows open because it's always in my
face earlier when the sun was a little
more up
that thing was on my chair and just be
hitting my eyes but like i'd
ignore it so i wouldn't directly hit but
it just hit my face
it was kind of annoying yeah that always
like
this is basically how my room would
always be yeah it's always so dark you
know it's so funny so i was talking so
much sorry baby you're not in on this
conversation but i was telling them how
the old camera that i had it would never
focus and right now this whole time that
you were talking and explaining
this new camera wasn't focusing either i
don't know it must just be
the way cameras are i don't know but i
just in case you guys noticed i noticed
too okay
i'm laughing too anyway sorry back to
your story the next
thing we are going to do we're gonna
move my entire pc setup we're just gonna
move it
right here to this area and then we're
gonna move my bed
to this window yeah for the house i'm
going to disassemble my pc
from the cord and stuff put it away and
then we're just going to move this we're
going to put the desk
right here right kind of like what you
see this
that's where it's the pc is going gonna
be how about your bed my bed
is gonna be moved this way
where the window is maybe out this one
and then this
little thing this drawer is gonna be
right here yeah you know it's funny
that thing used to be above this when it
was over here yeah and we moved it so
now it's going to be reunited
i know right it's going to be right
under but we're probably going to have
to move that
because it's probably too high or
something huh you think it's okay yeah i
think it's just good
all right so i'm gonna set up the gopro
do a time lapse show you guys this
entire
processor let's do it also i just can't
stop laughing at how funny it is that
this camera
is way blurrier than the last one
i don't know if you guys have some tips
let me know i don't know how to
um make this camera not be so blurry i'm
going to ask nikki if she has any idea
what are you doing you weirdo smell your
hair well thank you i just showered
it's nice and clean for you you should
smell his hair his hair is the best
look at those curls those magnificent
girls
how they turn out magnificent look at me
i dare you to smell it
oh smell the chem with the perm chemical
no it smells good now he showered today
too
we're all clean this doesn't mean it
lingers that smell
lingers on mine never it never goes away
it's not bad
yeah it smells like popcorn sometimes
maybe something like a weird
flavor because it's like curly curly
fries it smells like yes
just kidding just because it's curly
all right how are you liking your camera
by the way oh it's so funny i was just
telling them that
the other camera the sony was so bad it
never focused it was
horrible and then as i started talking
to isaac and then i was explaining his
room situation
it's so out of focus so i'm like is it
just these cameras
cameras will do that i guess i don't
know but you look really good in this
lighting
really you look like a model are you
gonna help us move too
oh i can i can help i finish filming a
cooking video today
we're gonna actually know a portion of
it i need a marinade right now
i'm waiting for it to marinate but i
don't have anything to do right now i
might as well help you guys
perfect we could use the extra set of
hands so what are we doing today we're
rearranging isaac's room
let's do it all right so we
finally moved your desk and what did we
discover we discovered that uh
oh my gosh
we discovered this what is this that's
on my feet
and my rose that's your feet you just
keep touching this wall is that how this
wall is gonna look
maybe say goodbye to a clean wall
actually maybe not
no i will i promise you it will but you
want to get the magic eraser and try
cleaning it i mean we're gonna cover
with i knew it i knew you're gonna say
that i knew it i caught it in my head
lower though no that's not going there
his bed's glowing there
yeah this is going on this wall what's
going to be behind your bed then the
window i don't know
this bed right now this oh wow probably
nothing's probably going to be clean huh
cause your bed's been covering it yeah
probably gonna be the cleanest
i say go get a magic eraser and try
wiping it
please we're gonna cover it that's gross
look at this hard line too you know
exactly where you put your feet
no no this is the line where yeah i know
exactly don't you put your feet on that
yeah i do exactly
this is so funny you're such a 12 year
old boy this is such a boy
thing you could feel like compared to
the wall like yeah
that's so true this feels like the walls
from a disneyland you know when you walk
through like the
the lines and stuff yeah and you feel
the walls it's like years of grime
it's like slimy look at this dry at the
same time yeah you can feel the actual
wood
whoa that's a deep indent whoa
that's true oh maybe you can like lift
it up one time when i was moving isaac i
was like maybe
nine or ten and when we moved my bed
there's like the wall of just burgers
that's what i used to do when i was when
i was going to sleep i'd be like
i can't breathe oh i got burgers in my
nose yeah i just
laid there all day just became my nose
and we're like
you didn't have tissues next to you it
was just too far to reach
oh my goodness the walls like right now
oh and had like bars on my
headboard headboard yeah so it was bars
like i could put my hand through it well
at least you don't have that
what do you think about daddy's story i
think that's a little more gross yeah
cause isaac has tissues right
there let me try my new zoom oh very
slow
very slow zoom but he has
tissues right there
whoa it's zooming in way more than i
wanted
i love your curls you look so good
thanks i can't see it so i don't
i don't even get to enjoy my own yay i
get to enjoy them well you got to enjoy
my blue hair more than i did
true but you get to at least look down
and see your own blue hair look oh
true yeah that's a big point i don't
know i have to
oh yeah curly hair no you're messing up
the curls
and then the cats come down here
sometimes so some of the cat fries here
how cute there's like a huge buildup of
cat fur
you should look at the place where his
zone i know behind the couch yeah i
vacuumed back there recently and the
whole vacuum got clogged up with
fur and i didn't even fully clean it so
you're gonna clean the carpet but not
the wall
no fine let's just cover it it could be
your memory of when your desk was there
it looks like there was a fire there
it does here
careful yeah yeah careful
we'll figure it out just leave it case
it's harder to try to get the chair out
than figuring out how to move the bed
[Music]
all right here's the final product there
we go we're
all moved you okay yep
i'm just setting up how it used to be so
what do you think
personally i like it yeah
this is all your idea i like this i like
playing and then
missing staring at some parts nice i'm
glad you like this because
when i made this i'm like i don't think
he's gonna really care for it but i'm
glad you like it and then now you don't
have the sun
blurring in your face yeah that's gonna
be awesome
i can have my windows open now now you
can have your not only the blinds open
but then
the entire window open to let some air
in because this is the stuffiest room in
the whole house
i think it's because you're a pc that's
why i made sure to like leave the
purifier in here for you so at least you
can get some purified stuffy air no it's
been a lot less
stuffy right ever since we got it yeah
and then now you have all this room here
for activities
what activities were you saying you're
gonna use it for uh for pe
yeah when you're doing your pe class the
only thing i wanna do is
i'm gonna have to tilt my monitor
constantly so like
whenever i'm eating in my room i'm gonna
have to move my chair here
i can connect it to bluetooth told my
monitor to see you right here i think it
fits watch bring the table
honestly though i feel like the way your
room was set up previously it was way
more efficient
because this way it's like really tight
over here
it's like a very tight squeeze to get
through here i mean sure you have all
this space but i think the previous
version was the most efficient but
you want to change so now you get to
explore this change
and you can lower your chair too finally
heavy not to lower chairs
you said you're finally heavy enough to
lower chairs yeah i mean
almost i just have to push a little bit
i could do it for writing too oh true
it does work like a student desk
remember those desks i love those desks
i love to
for some reason those desks were really
good for packing bags
i could like that one from school yeah
but no i'm talking about the old school
ones i had it angled like that
we didn't like we didn't have them in
our schools unless we had a really old
school
and then they had the stopper right here
yeah that one and then you could flip it
open you know which one i'm talking
about
yeah like you've always wanted to have
those the ones where you have to
in order to exit you have to open it oh
i had one of those
i never had those were kind of like they
were wack
[Music]
yeah but i did have one of those i felt
like that was a trap too you couldn't
really put anything in your desk right
those are like smaller spaces
yeah well those were like in high school
so we didn't really keep things in the
desk because
people would change out different
periods but like we would have baskets
under the desk oh you had to carry your
own books i'm gonna carry books i wish i
could do that because then that means
you had your own locker
i never had a locker do you have a
locker i had a locker
oh my school so it's not so crazy for
you guys it's like you didn't have a
locker
do you have a locker in elementary no
middle school i mean i did have a locker
for pe
that's something that was the only
locker i had
it's not a pleasant experience of a
locker you can't really develop a
relationship with
yeah i always wanted to decorate my
locker and stuff i never got one it
looks so fun
but at least i didn't have to carry my
books back and forth true
never decorated my locker either i
wouldn't have expected you to
also you don't want to decorate your
locker because if you made any enemies
people come after you they'll know
exactly what locker you have no i mean
the inside
yeah well are you happy with your room
yeah i like it your rearranged room
hope you guys enjoyed that video once
again big shout outs to squarespace for
sponsoring today's video
all right little information about
squarespace squarespace gives people a
powerful and beautiful online platform
for which people can create their own
custom
website for example if you want to
create a photography website to showcase
your work
squarespace offers professional
portfolio designs that allow you to
customize the layout
look and feel so you can make it your
own then
when people want to hire you for
photography add online booking and
scheduling to your website with
squarespace
taking the hassle out of coordinating
calendars with clients
squarespace also has powerful tools for
growing an audience through email create
email content which matches the feel of
your website so everything feels
consistent and stays
effective go to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch
go to squarespace.com tiffincase to save
10 off your first purchase of a website
or domain
i actually used to do photography so
this is something had it been around
when i was doing photography i would
have totally jumped on anyways thank you
squarespace once again be sure to check
them out
[Music]
me